hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in the beginning of book 10 of his
Republic Plato is going to discuss the
relationship of artistic production or
as he's gonna call it here imitation
mimesis to truth reality unity the
things that matter to him and to some of
his interlocutors the most and he's
going to distinguish three basic types
of producers three agents of creation
and each one is making something that
has a certain kind of being but the
question is what type of being does it
have
so for Plato in this this section he's
going to say that we have God we have
the crafts person the person who
actually works with raw materials and
creates something that we would say is
real and then we have the artist the
person who is creating something that's
not quite as real but is a
representation or an imitation and Plato
thinks that imitation doesn't just take
place in terms of the artist in turn and
the crafts person the the you know
depiction of the thing and the existing
thing
it also takes place in terms of the
thing that the crafts person creates out
of raw material or already formed
material and the form or idea of the
thing itself what it is for that thing
to be what it is if you like its essence
so let's talk about each of these in in
turn I've got this schema up here on the
board for you that sets these these
things out Plato thinks that what's most
real are forms or ideas the a dose or
idea and this is a unity so as opposed
to he uses the example of beds
as opposed to a whole bunch of
individual beds or chairs which are
actually existing things created by some
craft person we might say today
industrial processes but those
ultimately go back to some sort of craft
person creating it this is a unity it is
always the same thing it is most real
it's not something that we can
materially or sense orally encounter
because it doesn't have material being
it has a greater kind of being what we
might call the being that ideas have our
ideal being and Plato thinks that when a
crafts person is making whatever it is
that that the craft person is making a
statue wellactually a statue would be
the artistic production so let's not
take that a chair creating something
along those lines a utensil of some sort
they are looking to the model the
archetype the pattern these are other
ways of talking about the form or the
idea and the idea is what gives to the
thing that we're looking at the thing
that the craft person produces it's very
identity as what it is and it also
allows us to identify it as something it
gives an intelligibility to it so when
we look at it share we don't actually
you know do this process of comparing
the ideal chair with the image that we
have of the chair but something like
that according to Plato is going on in
our mind whether we realize it or not so
the craft person is already an imitative
artist in a certain respect a producer
somebody who's engaged in poiesis now
when we turn to the artist I should have
put here imitation right the artist is
also engaged in imitation as well but
they are not imitating the ideal form of
the thing they're not they're not
looking to that instead they're looking
to the
of material objects so the artist may be
depicting a chair or a desk or a pair of
scissors a pair of old peasant boots or
they may be depicting human beings they
may be depicting waterfalls landscapes
all those sorts of things now those are
actually produced by craftspeople those
would presumably have been produced by
some sort of agency beyond the human but
they are still a multiplicity and we can
talk for example of the ideal human
being the form of human being as opposed
to all the existing human beings the
painting the portrait of a human being
or the video like you're watching right
now is an imitation it's removed so to
speak in reality and in truth from that
of which it is the imitation it is
intelligible insofar as it successfully
imitates the thing that is is supposed
to depict so if you're watching this
video right now you are in effect
watching something that is an imitation
of me the existing thing which is an
imitation of the ideal form of human
being which is also the form that that
you yourself would be participating in
so the artist doesn't actually you might
say short-circuit things and go right to
the form of the thing so the artist is
working with a copy of a copy and what
can you say about copies they're not the
whole thing the artist is working with
something that is removed further and
further away from the reality the truth
if we want to think about this in terms
of a continuum as we move this way we
not only get to greater unity
we get to greater reality or being and
we get to greater truthfulness this is
the most true this is less true this
barely contains any truth at all
according to Plato so what are the
implications of this well this means
that mimetic art imitative art and that
includes poetry that includes sculpture
that includes painting that includes all
sorts of other things in our own times a
video production is in a certain sense a
falling away from what's really true
what's truly real if you want to engage
in a little key azzam there so we have
these these three and we shouldn't mix
them up according to Plato it's very
important to recognize that we as the
producers like if I whip up a cake or
something like that I'm actually
participating in some sort of ideal of
cake and making something exist as I do
that the person who takes a photograph
of that cake or writes a blog entry
about that cake they are further away
not just from the cake but from the
ideal cake the cake is kind of a funny
example because you know we we generally
do encounter it in terms of its sensuous
properties but we could think of an
ideal here so we want to be able to
distinguish according to Plato these
three producers these three creators if
you like and the kinds of things that
they are involved in producing or
creating this is an interesting set of
passages and I'll just close by pointing
this out Plato often talks as if the
forms simply are or if they come from
anything
come from the form of the good or they
come from the form of the beautiful in
this case Plato is talking about God
actually or the divine however you want
to understand it some sort of agency
transcendent to us as creative of the
forms generative of the forms he doesn't
go into any explanation about this but
this is an important point here so we
have creation or production artistry of
a sort in many respects and what this
means is that the artists are actually
the least of the creators they are the
farthest away from genuine creation or
production and they're stuck within a
realm of images
you